I want to know about this is it
I mean yeah Mary story is it a little
weird what they were both here
not that you're both here but at the
same because I got Lauren he's got Laura
and Laura's you know all right what do
you think about the choir last night I
mean that's the him I want to hear are
there times as you were going through
marriage story you're like this is
really painful for me to kind of watch a
little bit of my life it's not my life
but watching the actors give go to such
raw real emotional places that was that
was hard but but also gratifying because
it was they were doing it in service in
the movie well I think it's everyone who
has ever been divorced it was a party
felt like our lives that's why we were
like
it was just so on a level that were so
real it wasn't romanticized or no it was
it wasn't glossy it was just real just
it's heartbreaking it was heartbreaking
can you tell me about this dress please
because it's also heartbreaking very
good way this is Dior
he's wearing - your - you own that and
you own that will you pick a card any
card and answer the question inspired by
1917 what was your biggest challenge
getting ready for Oscar night and I feel
like the joint getting ready of the
mothers just swap out those two soldiers
with our mum but with our mother it's a
lie yeah it was like it's that moment
where you take them too often
well I think we're gonna take them to
the Governor's Ball we're gonna have a
big party back at the house with all our
friends
oh you're going to throw the party yes
no we're we're all in we got we got
friends from New York we got friends
from everywhere and it's like a wedding
but we're not getting married
hopefully you bring home an Oscar with
that hopefully
[Music]